they are conflating gender and sex
because on one hand they say well you
got your biological sex but then your
gender is whatever social construct but
then they turn around and say that trans
women are women
so a man who who identifies with the
with the gender the social construct of
womanhood actually is a woman so if you
can't you can laugh what you want but
you are this is a logical problem you
are conflating sex and gender just by
saying that so that's the problem
there's biological sex and then there is
gender identity part of me wants to ask
why you care so much uh because it's
really not that big of a deal oh yeah
um i i loved it i'd love to answer that
question i care about the truth so so
basic truth matters i want to live in a
society where people care about the
truth and we're grounded in truth i care
about children and this these insane
ideas about gender are being are being
voiced on kids
um and that that bothers me quite a bit
i care about the women who are having
their opportunities stolen from them i
care quite a bit yeah